YouTube is filled with the glowing
endorsements of skillshare but much of
this is just due to skillshare's Smart
positioning and branding behind the
scenes skillshare doesn't accomplish
anything notably great in fact they have
multiple notable negative attributes
they have pretty shady free trial
renewal and cancellation policies the
bottom line is that skillshare just
isn't worth it you're basically getting
a discounted version of YouTube that you
have to pay exorbitant fees for if any
other company was offering the same
service they would have gotten shredded
by the community but because skillshare
is such a big player within the
sponsorship scene no YouTuber wants to
speak out against them